[Music]
I'm [ __ ] down dude I'm [ __ ] that
dude I'm [ __ ] the end you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
I really want to try to become a pro CS
player oh no no dude I swear to god [ __ ]
you have you ever tried looking up the
male porn stars
what people reported me for that are you
serious chat you can't handle seeing you
can't handle seeing a [ __ ] dick just
chill just wait everyone just wait
hold your horses get
[Music]
that just happened oh my god get fog
ah
as a kid Jarrett summit 1g Lazar sauce
csgo for the first time while hanging
around a card shop and the rest is
history I used to go to this card shop
and one day I walked in and they had all
these computers set up
they were playing counter-strike and
how's the first time I've ever seen
counter-strike I thought it was the
coolest looking [ __ ] thing summit 1g
has kept the moniker 1g from a community
forum he was a part of back in the days
of early counter-strike some it was
actually a joker
oMG but then because the actual 1g clubs
stopped doing like scrimmages and like
died at the end of all it's like a scrim
team by the counter shake 1g they
brought some it in at the end I think he
just wrapped it for fun and then on his
brand people started doing the 1g thing
and he's holding on tightly to those 2
archaic characters is just so
quintessential summit he's the brash
veteran the no-nonsense old head who's
been here since the beginning and is it
going to change his ways for anybody I'm
[ __ ] that dude I'm [ __ ] that dude
I'm [ __ ] yeah
getting off line guys later and that's
why the cs community the 1g crew and
those who have been twitch fans from the
very beginning loved him so much
been watching you for a long time now
finally give you some support love Yukio
cute chicks thanks man I appreciate that
dude you very much since it's been
possible to stream CS summit 1g has been
doing it
sumit created his twitch count on
November 30th 2011 and started streaming
regularly October 2013 from the
beginning he's always been all about the
game no matter what he's playing he's
constantly trying to get better and
bringing you along for the ride I killed
all of them everybody's dead summit is
widely recognized as one of the first to
make it big as a streamer on Twitch and
it's not too hard to see his influence
on the platform with a handful of top
streamers crediting him as one of the
reasons they wanted to get into
streaming in the first place and the
reason I started streaming was because
of summit I was always watching Summit
play in fact then it was like worthy how
much he streamed it like inspired me he
quit his job and on that it was I was
like I want to do that even in the early
days of twitches mainstream relevancy
back in 2015 some it was drawing a large
audience even by today's lofty standards
in August 2015 he averaged more than
16,000 viewers at a time since then he's
managed to hover around those numbers
with outstanding consistency peaking at
more than 28 K in January of 2018 with a
650 dollar donation from M dude we're
gonna [ __ ] add it up so ok [ __ ] now
you're for sure the number one donator
on stream some it's kind of just like
you and me he certainly wears his
emotions on his sleeve and he's not
afraid to full-on tilt off in front of
thousands of fans [ __ ] this game I'm out
of here everybody could suck my [ __ ]
wiener all right
I never liked any of you guys [ __ ]
everything games play with our emotions
they pull us in and make us invested in
our own success
oh what the [ __ ]
and nobody embodies that feeling of
being encapsulated more than summat he's
fiery he appreciates a good meme and
well what would you do if there was a
child right in front of you I'd punch
that little kid in his [ __ ] teeth
during the infancy of Counter Strike
global Offensive summit made the jump
from streamer to competitive player he
had toyed with the idea of competing as
he was beginning to stream but committed
to it in 2015 I really want to try to
become a pro CS player and I'm even
willing to put in the time to get that
done he played in tournaments with
torqued and area51 gaming to
middle-of-the-pack results but to his
ever-growing fan base those results were
mostly irrelevant killing summit through
the Hutt a wall bang on nothing that's
gonna do it he'll get the round and how
many clutches is that for him in a lot
of ways his semi-pro career could never
fail just because of how nicely it
paired with his stream he was constantly
trying to improve and focus on his
gameplay just like his views which made
him more relatable than a lot of pros
I'm still gonna obviously be the same
streamer you know I'm starting to be
talking to you guys a bunch they're
gonna be thanks and subs Thank You
donations just having a chill time think
of it as a twitch reality show where our
protagonist summit has quit his job and
is chasing the professional
counter-strike dream and he's taking his
fans along for the ride my spot for me
in addition to his ability to balance an
urge to compete with a successful stream
summit has also been able to
successfully jungle multiple games which
is something that many streamers
struggle with even in those early years
summit played Daisy and rust on lawn
with CS go yo bro I just spawned two
seconds ago fully [ __ ] naked why are
you trying to shoot me with your [ __ ]
arrows as long as he was playing a
shooter people would show up and watch
Cadell [ __ ] lady summit stream was
steady but his hunger for more
competitive success had not subsided so
in 2016
he gave it another shot this time with
splice during which he would compete in
the largest event of his pro career
Dreamhack Austin 2016 doesn't think that
splice are gonna be playing that
aggressively now can we shut down
stomach walking right up there over
towards me with attack 9 is gonna find
another frag on a taco Austin was also
the site of the most memorable moment of
summit's professional career a play that
will go down in counter-strike history
as one of the game's biggest fails and
now it's summit in the 1v1 to try and
close this out again smugly bug be
playing it aggressively no that clutch
hit and blank will close out not number
116 to elect 1508 what summit clutches
the round for his team but in retrospect
his celebration was a little premature
as he walked directly into the flames of
his own molotov dying and handing over
the round to CLG as cringy as it may be
to watch this might just be the
quintessential summit moment now when he
died of a molotov by yourself it's
called pulling a summit
it's the perfect intersection of his
high skill and at times
goofy persona it's the type of thing as
chat would flame and four on stream and
he did it at a pro see Esther namond
like when it happened I was like dude my
life is over
like I can't even step foot
in the world right now like I just my
life's over
and what's more is that sense that
summit has owned his mistake
he's wielded it and it could be argued
that he's seen even more success as a
streamer because of it kinda like
created a name for ourself a little bit
after his time was splice summit played
with mythic a semi-pro csgo team filled
with popular streamers his time with
mythic allowed him to scratch his itch
for competitive play but also stream the
games live on his channel giving him and
his viewers the best of both worlds as
summer 2017 rolled around summit was hit
by the same infatuation as almost every
other streamer and gamer in the FPS
world player unknowns battlegrounds I'm
it's an pub G's certainly flipped the
script on streaming shooters the pace of
play is perfect and gives streamers
ample time to interact with their chat
between games
I'm just so gosh-darn just substitute
pay me thousands of dollars every day
aren't doing what I like and the video
game I play has been anything but
favorable don't worry I'll shake it off
later in a GTR that you're helping me
pay for I appreciate it the whole
experience is more like a television
show or a movie rather than constant
gameplay since battle Royales have blown
up summit has stayed away from
competitive play just as big
personalities like shroud of being able
to focus on being professional streamers
rather than professional gamers a
distinction that has become a lot more
clear and plausible since battle Royales
have arrived
there it is boys summit 1g is an
old-school gamer he's been around since
the humble beginnings of both twitch and
eSports but even a guy with his feet as
cemented in the scene as summit is isn't
immune to the hate as we saw earlier
this year
yo I'm catch come on guys just relax
okay now know why guys are freaking out
summit took major heat from his fan base
for his choice to stream for tonight
with controversial YouTube star
Jake Paul bro you're disappointed that
guy is playing a video game with another
human being that you you happen to not
like from a youtube series that you
don't watch hey relax at first glance it
may seem pretty tame a harmless
marketing move to collaborate with an
incredibly famous person in the biggest
game in the world but this is gaming
where loyalty is everything no I love
you homies I'll blow this point as
you're playing with him I still think
you're great but can't watch this with a
minute love it a man feel free I
understand kaboom so now that we're here
and someone likes summit the guy who
quit his job to become a streamer years
ago he's streaming the new hot game with
a millionaire clickbait enthusiast his
fans really put him on blast if you're
gonna look at it from like a business
perspective playing with them ain't good
for you
like who gives a [ __ ] how many subs they
have the whole ear somehow becomes
completely cancer and your entire
environment and channel becomes garbage
you know you're gaming with someone like
just a game with them and like it
doesn't matter you know
you know who you who you and then Summit
reacted by doing a full stream without
interacting with this chat at all
everyone jumping down my throat about
playing a game playing some games with
Jake Paul and it's just like what did
you guys want me to do you know he DM me
and says hey man you ashamed of doing
what you want to be like don't talk to
me since that fateful April stream
summits viewership has taken a bit of a
dip he was averaging almost 20k viewers
in April dipping to just over 16 K in
May and then just over 14 K in July he
took a long time for eSports to be taken
seriously in the mainstream and it's for
that reason that it's fans can be
critical of their heroes they want
consistency absolute undying passion and
loyalty with that said fans of Summit
have historically been pretty hard on
their favorite streamer he often seems
to be the butt of their jokes even back
in 2016
summit was swatted by his own chat while
mobile streaming himself playing pokemon
go in a park I was holding my hands up I
was gonna make a move you know I was
gonna turn my stream off with one hand
you know I was a little nervous I mean
you got guys pointing rifles it they
weren't pistol yeah recently he's
admitted that he's developed a lot of
anxiety around streaming and that going
live has become a taxing and
overwhelming process coming in here in
front of you guys is it's all hardest
thing I've had to do in a long time I
know I've done this for years and it
just doesn't make sense to me why why
it's scary to get on why it's scary to
sit here in front of you guys why it's
scary to talk
we're back I'm hoping that we're here to
stay I hope we don't have any [ __ ]
problems I'm feeling healthy dude we're
in there we're in there everything's
everything's good man everything's good
everything's coming full circle
oh she you good you're a lucky guy acid
that was a headshot on my screen homey
that was a [ __ ] headshot on my screen
Channel want that slow-motion clipped
right now
the old guard of eSports eats somewhere
to go and someone to flame somewhere to
check up the new Call of Duty game or
get a nice daily dosage of streamer salt
and some it 1g will always be there for
that don't act like it was a skill-based
[ __ ] I [ __ ] you up summit listen
[ __ ] don't tell me how to play games
all right I've been playing them longer
than your whole life summit 1g isn't the
hero or the villain of the streaming
world he's simply adapting the way he
always has to be able to do 10k viewers
9k viewers 8k viewers playing any game
so that's the [ __ ] dream right in
there buzz you know you don't need to be
slain I don't need to be slammin Bruce
500k a month and [ __ ] dude to be happy
I'm very happy as we watch this world
grow there's more pressure on people
like summit than anyone else to play hot
games like fortnight or pub G to market
themselves the way the likes of ninja
shroud and doctor disrespect of being
able to some of you guys are ride or die
one jeez no matter what to goof off to
meme to be the five-tool streamer that
viewers have come to expect I think I
blocked them all some it was there when
it all started on Twitch and you better
believe he's going to scrap and claw to
stick around now that all eyes
on that purple Python summit 1g isn't
going anywhere thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button